تعهد رئيس المجلس الوطني الانتقالي الليبي
مصطفى عبد الجليل بالحفاظ على وحده البلاد
واجهاض اي محاولات لتهديدها جاءت اقوال
عبد الجليل مع انطلاق مؤتمر الميثاق
الوطني في مدينه مصراته تحت شعار وحده
التراب
[موسيقى]
الليبي
حياكم الله نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
عنوانين رئيسيين ما حاجه ليبيا لميثاق
وطني وهي تمر في مرحله انتقاليه نحو نظام
سياسي
ديمقراطي وما خيارات النخبه السياسيه
والثقافيه الليبيه لحفظ الوحده الترابيه
والاجتماعيه
للبلاد
كان للمؤتمر الذي تستضيفه مراطه هذه
الايام ان يمر بليبيا مرور الكرام لولا ان
البلاد التي تحررت قبل سنه من حكم العقيد
القذافي وشرعت للتو تتلمس طريقها نحو
الديمقراطيه وبناء الدوله الحديثه تمر
خاصه في الاوت الاخيره بمنعطفات حاسمه وهي
تحاول حث الخطى نحو هذه الاهداف ورغم قله
المعلوم ما حول هذه المؤتمر الا ان المتاح
منها يقول ان اشغاله تجري برعايه من
المجلس الوطني الانتقالي تحت شعار ليبيا
وطننا يسع الجميع وهو النسخه الثانيه مما
يعرف بمؤتمر الميثاق الوطني لقاء يجمع تحت
خيمته ولمده يومين شخصيات وجهات تمثل
النسيج الوطني والمدني في ليبيا يفترض بها
ان تناقش واقع الوحده الوطنيه في البلاد
والتحديات القائمه في طريق الانتقال
الديمقراطي فيها يتزامن مؤتمر مراطه مع
بروز ردود فعل واسعه حول اعلان مجلس برقى
اعلان الاقليم فدراليه وهي الخطوه التي
نظر اليها على انها استباق للدستور الذي
سيحدد شكل النظام السياسي
للبلاد في هذا السياق بالذات دع مصطفى عبد
الجليل رئيس المجلس الوطني الانتقالي
المطالبين بالفيدرالية
لان
الليبيين ليسوا على استعداد لتقسيم بلدهم
على حد
وصفه نحن نريد ان نقيم دوله القانون لابد
ان يعو اخوتنا في برقا ان بينهم المندسين
وبينهم من تاخر كثيرا في الالتحاق بركب
هذه الثوره ويريد الان مكانا وبينهم من هم
من اعوان النظام السابق ارجو ارجو ان يعو
ذلك جيد
ولكننا على ثقه بان اهل برقه سيكون في
مستوى المسؤوليه ونحن كمجلس وطني مستعدون
للحوار لا نقصي احد لا نهم احد لا نخون
احد ولكن ليبيا وحده واحده اليوم وغدا ولو
بالقوه لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من
طرابلس موسى الكوني عضو المجلس الوطني
الانتقالي من بنغازي معنا الدكتور صالح
سنوسي الكاتب والمحلل واستاذ العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه بنغازي ابدا معك موسى
الكوني لماذا مؤتمر ميثاق وطني اصلا لماذا
ميثاق وطني الان ما حاجه ليبيا اليه في
هذا
الوقت لقد جرى اعداد لهذا المؤتمر منذ
فتره ليست بالقصيره وانعقد المؤتمر
التحضيري في طرابلس وحضرته العديد من
الشخصيات الليبيه و وتم الاعداد في الواقع
لهذا المؤتمر ان يكون في م رات اشبه ما
يكون ببدايه مصالحه بين الليبيين وبدايه
التحاور بين الليبيين بعضهم بعض ل لوضع
رؤيه لليبيا
الجديده لهذا كان هذا المؤتمر فقط تزامن
مع مع الدعوات التي نسمعها الان من برقه
حول الفيدراليه
اي ونحن جميعا لسنا كاعضاء
المؤتمر المجلس الو فقط انما كليبي
ككل اتحدنا على على اسقاط النظام واشتركنا
في هذه الثوره ونحن متحدون الان على انها
ليبيا واحده ولا يمكن ان تتجزا ليبيا باي
حال من الاحوال هذا راي الليبيين من يعني
راي الليبيين في كل المناطق بمختلف
شرائحهم واتجاهاتهم ط لكن هذه الدعوه كانت
مفاجئه هنا نعم من هنا ياتي شعار وحده
التراب الليبي اذا دكتور السنوسي ما الذي
يهد
وحده ليبيا الان ما الحاجه لهذا الشعار
تحديدا هو الحقيقه قبل قبل ان نتحدث على
مساله التهديد لان الى الان حتى يعني
المؤتمرون لم يعلنوا انفصال او شيء من هذا
القبيل انما اعلنوا عن
قيام بمعنى اخر نظام ولائي انا ما الماخذ
الذي اخذه على هؤلاء انهم طبعا ليس الراي
الذي عبروا عنه فاللبيب قاموا بثوره من
اجل ترسيخ مجموعه من القيم والمبادي اهمها
هي الديمقراطيه والديمقراطيه ايضا هي
مجموعه من المبادي والاليات ما اخذه على
هؤلاء انهم لم يحترموا هذه المبادي ولا
هذه الاليات اي انهم قاموا
ويعني باجتماع ثم اعلنوا عن قيام مؤسسات
بصرف النظر عن مدى يعني مصداقيه هذا
الاعلان من عدمه وانما لم يحترموا اليات
الديمقراطيه وهي الانتخاب والاستفتاء
والتظاهر ولم يحترموا
ايضا معايير الديمقراطيه وهي معيار
الاقليه والاكثر فهم جاؤوا واعلنوا عن
مجموعه من المؤسسات واعلنوا عن قيام نظام
لائي اذا صح التعبير اداري وسياسي ايضا
دون ان يطرحوا هذه الفكره
ويجادل مع من يختلف معهم على الاقل حتى في
المنطقه التي يتحدثون باسمها اذا هم
صادروا حق الاكثريه في ان تبدي رايها فانا
لا اعترض على ان يقول ان يقولوا نحن نريد
نظام ولائي هذا من حقهم ربما اذا راوا في
ذلك خدمه لمصلحه ليبيا ولكن عليهم ان
يطرحوا هذه الفكره على من يعتقدون انهم
لهم مصلحه في ذلك فاذا فازت هذه هذه
الفكره باغلبيه الليبيين واقل حتى في
المنطقه التي تحدثون باسمها نستطيع ان
نقول اذا هذه الفكره في مصلحه ليبيا اما
ان ياتوا هكذا ويعلنوا عن قيام مؤسسات
فاعتقد ان هذا يعني يعني يثير كثير من الش
يتحدثون عن عن السباق مع الوقت يريدون ان
ان يقوموا بهذه الخطوه
قبل اعلان الدستور وهذا بالنسبه لهم مهم
اريد فقط موسى الكوني فيما يتعلق بهذه
النقطه مصطفى عبد الجليل يتحدث عن دول
مجاوره يتهمها
باذكى النزعات التي تهدد وحده ليبيا من له
المصلحه في هذه المرحله بتهديد وحده
ليبيا
والله ا بدون شك هناك اجنده خفيه لا
نستطيع ان ان نذكر لك دوله بعينها او او
او الهدف من
من يعني التوجه الى تقسيم ليبيا وهذا كان
موجود حتى من بدايات الثوره هناك العديدين
حاولوا ان ان يقنعوا الثوار بان يكتفوا
بما تحصلوا عليه وهو منطقه برقه او
المنطقه الشرقيه فقط ويكون ذلك اشبه ما
يكون بحل بين بين الثوار والنظام انذاك اي
وقد تكون هناك اجنده خفيه في هذا الاتجاه
من منذ ذلك الوقت ا وهذا يعني يدعون الى
الشك الى العديد من الدول بانها وراء
هذا يعني هذا التوجه بتقسيم ليبيا ا برغم
كما شار سيده الدكتور ان فعلا يعني هذا
التقسيم او هذا الخيار الذي دعوا ال اليه
ما لم يتفقوا اهل برق انفسهم يفترض ه يكون
في استفتاء يفترض ان نتناقش ان ننتظر حتى
حتى نختار المؤتمر الوطني اللي اللي في
داخله سيتم مناقشه كل هذه الامور على شكل
ليبيا كيف يكون ستكون ولايات ستكون
محافظات تكون بلديات
يعني يفترض يكون خيار الشعب الليبي لو
ارادوا ان يكونوا ولايات او فدراليه او او
اي شكل كان ل يعني شكل ليبيا القادم ولكن
ان ان تحتلي اريد ان اعود لموضوع والفكره
يعني
الفدراليه ولكن قبلها اريد ان توقف عند
هذا التصريح لمصطفى عبد الجليل عن اهام
دول مجاوره دكتور السنوسي يعني هناك من
يرى ان هذه محاوله
ل
تصدير الازمه للخارج بمعنى ان استعمال
شماعه خارجيه بدل التركيز على عوامل
داخليه ربما محاوله للهروب منها حتى هل
هذا برايك تشخيص
دقيق انا حقيقه لست يعني في المكان الذي
يشغله المستشار مصطفى عبد الجليل لانني
انا شخصيا ليست لدي وليست تحت يدي يعني
مستندات وادله على مثل
هذه الوقائع ولكن طالما هو قال ذلك قد
يكون لديه وهو مطالب بذلك ان يعرض ما يقع
تحت يده من ادله او براهين على وجود هذه
الوقائع يعني انا شخصيا ليست لدي ولم اسمع
بذلك ومع ذلك ومع ذلك اتصور انا ان اي حدث
سياسي كبير بحجم الثوره الليبيه في منطقه
حساسه لابد ان يعني يغري البعض بان يكون
لديه تاثير هنا وهناك في صنع الاحداث وفي
التاثير على مسار مستقبل الدوله الليبيه
يعني اتصور منطقيا وهذا ربما يعني من
اعمال السياسه يعني علينا ان نتوقع ذلك
يعني العالم ليس مسكونا بالملائكه وانما
هو صراع ارادات ووحدات النظام الدولي كلها
يعني تقودها المصلحه وتستخدم القوه بكل
يعني بكل اشكالها وبالتالي اتوقع ان يكون
هناك اغراء ولكنني لا استطيع ها ان اتهم
طرف بعينه طالما انه ليس لدي ادله بينما
المستشار مصطفى عبد الجليل باعتباره في
موقع السلطه ولديه طبعا وسائل يستطيع ان ي
بواسطتها يستطيع ان يطلع ما اذا كانت هناك
يعني وقائع حقيقيه فهو طبعا مطالب بان اذا
اذا سمحت له الظروف ذلك احيانا رجال
الدوله يعني هناك قضايا قد تكون من الصعب
او الامن القومي نفسه لا يسمح بالبحث
بالكشف عنها في لحظه ما ولكن يكشف عنها في
لحظه لاحقه طيب ربما يعني ولكن في النهايه
لب المشكله ما هو هل قضيه التهميش
تلقى الاهتمام الكافي هل هناك محاوله جاده
لحلها سنطرح هذا الموضوع بعد الفاصل ارجو
ان تبقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا من جديد الى حلقتنا التي تتناول
افاق مؤتمر الميثاق الوطني المنعقد في
مدينه مراطه الليبيه موسى الكوني اثرت
نقطه هامه في بدايه الحديث تحدثت عن غياب
عنصر المصالحه الوطنيه وبالفعل يعني خلال
هذه الفتره لم نسمع باي جهود حقيقيه في
هذا
الاتجاه بالعكس يعني نسمع كلمات مثل
التهميش خصوصا من الشرق هل فعلا التهميش
اللي هو لا ينطبق فقط على ليبيا وانما على
عموم العالم العربي هل هو عامل اذكاء
لكثير من المشاكل بما فيها التوجهات
الانفصاليه التي نسمع بها
الان هو العامل
الاول يعني معهم حق في بنغازي عندما طننا
بنغازي من المطار الذي بني من من الستينات
او قبل ذلك يعني غير المعقول غير من
المعقول ان دوله بتروليه من 42
عاما ولم يكن في مطار ولم تم انشاء مطار
جديد في في مدينه مثل بنغازي المدينه
الثانيه فما بك باقي البنيه التحتيه يعني
فعلا بنغازي مهمشه ليس بنغازي فقط انما
البيضه اجدابيا درناه طبر هذه المناطق
همشت وهي المصدر الرئيسي لل للثروه
الليبيه وهو النفط في منطقه السرير
والبريج وغيرها اي
ف فله السبب اعتقد ليس في ليبيا فقط انما
في العالم فعلا التهميش هو العامل الاساسي
الذي جعل اهل اهل تونس ينتفضون كذلك جميع
جميع الانتفاضات التي حصلت الان في في في
في هذا الوطن الممتد
اذا المصالحه في ليبيا
اي هي العامل الرئيسي في الواقع في الوقت
الحالي الذي يفترض ان يتم التركيز عليه
نعم لم نتمكن ان نعطيه حقه نظرا ل كما
تعلمين عدم وجود
اي جيش بمعنى الكلمه او شرطه رجال شرطه في
الشوارع عدم
وجود هيمنه الدوله على مؤسساتها وعلى
منافذها او ومع انتشار السلاح فهذا اج نعم
عمليه المصالحه خاصه احنا مقبلين على
الانتخابات في الفتره القريبه فاهم ما
ينتظره الليبيون في الفتره القريبه هو
الانتخابات ولا بد ان تسبقه مصالحه ل لان
هذه الانتخابات لا نعلم كيف كيف ستقول ما
لم تسبق عمليه مصالحه وسعه النطاق في
ليبيا طيب دكتور سنوسي هل ترى فرصه حقيقيه
لبدء مثل هذا النوع من الحوار ربما ان صح
تعبير في ضوء هذه الدعوات التي تنطلق هل
هناك مثلا نافذه
ضيعت تقصدين يعني هذه الدعوه دعوه
الفيدراليه لا اقصد ان هذه المرحله
الجوهريه اللي كانت قبل الانتخابات قبل
اعلان الستور هل كانت هناك نافذه يمكن كان
ان يستغلها المجلس الانتقالي بحيث
يتم طمت هذه الجهات هذه المناطق بان هناك
فعلا جهود حقيقيه لتغيير واقع التهميش
الذي كان
يعيشونه نعم نعم هو المشكله ان طبعا نظام
القذافي ترك يعني ارثا ثقيلا على كل
المستويات ومن ضمنها ايضا التهميش وهو كي
نظام طبعا دكتاتوري حاول ان يستخدم سياسه
العقوبه كل المناطق التي يعتقد انها ليست
راضيه عن حكمه لابد ان يعاقبها وبالتالي
حصل هذا الذي نراه الان هي احساس مناطق
كثيره في ليبيا بالتهميش والاقصاء هذا امر
مؤكد طنا مين ربما هذه هي المشكله ما هي
الخيارات الان المتاحه لحلها
نعم الخيارات امام المجلس الانتقالي عليه
اولا ان يعلن عن سياسه واضحه بخصوص
التقسيم الاداري واللام مركزيه وان يصدر
قانون واضح على الاقل بالنسبه للمرحله ال
قيه ويكون في نفس الوقت هذا القانون او
هذه السياسه احد المنطلقات التي ستبنى
عليها مواد الدستور الليبي انا اعرف ان
الكثيرين من الذين انضموا الى الفيدراليه
هم انضموا بدافع الاحساس بالتهميش وانه
وان يعني الجماعه الذين طبعا طالبوا
بالفيدرالية
الفيدراليه واللام مركزيه وبالتالي لو
طرحت المركز باللام مركزيه بشكل عملي
فربما سيرون فيها افضل بكثير من
الفيدراليه التي هي طبعا نظام ايضا سياسي
وقانوني واداري ولا يخلو من خطوره قد يهدد
وحده الوطن وبالتالي المجلس الوطني الان
مطالب بان يطمئن كل مناطق ليبيا ليس شرقها
كل مناطق ليبيا وجنوبها ايضا وجزء من
غربها ايضا بان هناك نظام اداري وقانوني
سيكون في خدمه كل المناطق صغيرها يعني
والمدن وبالتالي على الاقل ينزع الحجج
التي قد يستخدمها من
اي يريدون ا ترجيح كفه
اي الفيدراليه اعتقد المجلس الان لديه
فصحه من الوقت لكي يعلن عن هذه الترتيبات
بشكل واضح وفي نفس الوقت اقول ان على
المجلس الانتقالي ان لا يهدد وان لا
يستخدم لغه التهديد ضد اي ليبي لان
الليبيون طبعا ثاروا ضد هذا النوع وانت
ترى دكتور وانت تر وانت ترى في هذا يعني
الحل هل تعتقد ان هذا سيحتوي المشكله
سيحتوي هذه الدعوات التي بدات تتصاعد
لهجتها وتيرتها في
[تصفيق]
الشرق انا اعتقد ان يعني حتى لا نبالغ في
الامر يعني هناك احصاء قامت به بعض
المؤسسات هنا ووجدت ان يعني الفيدراليين
لا يمثلون اكثر من 7% من مجتمع الشرق
الليبي اذا هؤلاء قه هم فقط يعني
استغلوا الاعلام واعلنوا عن هذا المشروع
والدليل انهم اقليه انهم لم مثل ما قلت في
السابق لم يجنحوا الى الوسائل الديمقراطيه
لم لم يطالبوا باستفتاء وربما ما شجعهم
على ذلك ربما ما شجعهم على ذلك موسى
الكوني ان هناك نوع من التذمر موجود يعني
هذا ما يقوله كثير من المراقبين تذمر من
تنامي نفوذ مدن مثل مراطه والزنتان على
العاصمه وباعتبارها ربما يعني قلب البلد
والباقين يشعرون بانهم خارج اللعبه
السياسيه
لا اظن ذلك سواء كانت مصراته او زنتان لقد
كانوا راس حربه في تحرير طرابلس وتحرير
المنطقه الغربيه بشكل
عام فهم ليس لهم نفوذ يذكر لا اعتقد ان
كانوا موجودين في هذا المعسكر او في تلك
البوابه او مطار طرابلس مثلا لا يعني ان
لديهم
نفوذ او ميزت ميزهم عن الليبيين
الاخرين ولكن هذه الدعوه على فكره هي ليست
حديثه انا اذكر قبل التحرير بحوالي شهرين
عقد مؤتمر بهذا الشان في بنغازي حضر حوالي
1 شخصيه حول الفيدراليه وكان هناك احتجاج
كبير من قبل الاخوه هناك في بنغازي ورفض
لهذه الفكره
ف التدمر يعني ليس تدمر لان ذلك الوقت لم
تحرر ليبيا بعد ولا زالت الثوره في
بداياتها ف فلا اظن ان ان ان بسبب هذا
التدمر الت تحدثت عنه اي بل هناك فكره
موجوده اساسا وقد تكون هناك بعض المبارات
خاصه بعد نقل
ال
المجلس الوطني من بنغازي الى طرابلس احسوا
اهل بنغازي بانهم اصبح في فرغ سياسي كبير
في المدينه ولم يعد لها اهميه ولم يعد
عليها تركيز اعلامي كما كان ونقلت هذه
المؤسسه انتقلت هذه المؤسسه المهمه واللي
هي المجلس الوطني الى الى طرابلس احس وك
لكن نوع من انواع
التهميش وقد طلبنا من رئيس الحكومه ان ان
يكلف احد احد وكلائه بالمنطقه الشرقيه
يقيم المنطقه الشرقيه بكافه وكلاء بقي
الوزارات وال الوكيل الثاني ايضا يكون في
منطقه سبها اي منطقه الجنوب في فزان معه
كافه وكلاء باقي الوزارات وتعطى لهم
ميزانيات وتكون ال مركزيه يعني لديهم
صلاحيات الوزراء في في هذا الاقليم في كل
اقليم هذا نوع من انواع الا مركزيه
بالاضافه
ل وزير الحكم المحلي ايضا لقد باشر في في
انشاء
اي ادارات تابعه له في في كل في كل بلديه
سابقه
يعني في كل اقليم را تكون هناك عدد كبير
من البلديات التابعين لوزير الحكم المحلي
ولديهم صلاحيات ايضا في
مناطقهم الصغيره فبهذا الشكل اعتقد هو
العلاج الذي يفترض ان نبدا فيه لان
الميزانيه لاع اخر سامحني يعني دكتور
سنوسي البعض يرى العلاج في اطلاق الاحزاب
ويعتبرون ان في النهايه شان بين الجهويه
والقبليه مشكله اساسيه قد يكون اطلاق
الاحزاب حل وهذا حصل يعني قبل ايام في
ليبيا كان هناك
اي اطلق حزب وهل تراه فعلا بدايه
الحل انا ارى ان طبعا الاحزاب هذه احدى
مكونات اي مجتمع يريد ان يسير نحو
الديمقراطيه يعني لا يمكن العصبوي والجهوي
والقبليه ان تكون نواه لدوله ديمقراطيه
حتى لو طبقت اليات الديمقراطيه في ظل
القبيله فما فهي ستكون ديمقراط
قبليه لا علاقه لها بموضوع الاكثريه
والاغلبيه الثابته بحسب المفهوم القبلي
اذا لابد من وجود احزاب سياسيه وايضا من
وجود منظمات المجتمع المدني هذا ضروري لاي
ديمقراطيه واعتقد ان المجتمع الليبي منذ
بدايه الثوره بدات هذه التجمعات ومكونات
المجتمع الليبي صحيح انه لم يستر حتى الان
قانون ليتعلق بالا احزاب ولكن ارى ان هناك
عده احزاب الان يعني تكونت في الواقع يعني
يعني هي موجوده الان ديفاكتو مثل ما
يقولون هي موجوده و وتعمل وتعمل بين يعني
في المجتمع مثلها مثل مكونات المجتمع
الاخرى ولو ان يعني الاحزاب الان اصبحت
غير ممنوعه يعني فقط يعتقد ان المجلس
الوطني اعتقد انه اصدر قرار او شيء من هذا
القبيل يلغي ما كان موجود في السابق وهو
انتهى وقت الحلقه اشكرك اشكرك دكتور
السنوسي شكرا جزيلا
لك كنت معنا من عفوا من بنغازي الدكتور
صالح السنوسي الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
واستاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه بنغازي
وشكرا جزيلا لموسى الكوني عضوء المجلس
الوطني الانتقالي من
طرابلس وشكرا لكم مشاهدينا الكرام على
متابعه هذه الحلقه من برنامج م وراء الخبر
في م
[موسيقى]
ah